we're going to do is take a few
questions from y'all in the audience so
let's start sort of from the beginning
at what point Justin did you know you
had made it you had become a star made
it um I don't know I mean like I still I
still haven't got to that point I'm
still like like this is amazing I kind
of just take it one step at a time I
don't really think about all that stuff
did you see it happening at all like
this did you say to yourself okay here's
here's here's the thing if I could just
go out and have a few people gather in
the scream that would be fun did you see
this is your sole career path was there
anything else to do no I mean like I
just post the videos on YouTube for fun
and nobody see those videos on YouTube
yeah so I just posted them for fun and
then you know it just escalated to this
so I never thought that this would
happen question number two where is
Justine alright
so question I know a lot of people were
into YouTube these days musicians on
YouTube what kind of advice would you
give to them to become you know doing
what you're doing I just like like I you
know I always say just go for it go for
your dream make sure to stay humble and
like I said before put God first yes my
tour is coming out this summer I'm sorry
she's opening I do yes I do I think I
mean you know I I know that he couldn't
maintain his schedule and I certainly
could maintain mine if I didn't have the
right stuff in my body and so I think
what Jamie is doing in schools around
the country is gonna catch on like
wildfire more real proud of him and it's
an important issue so we're excited
about that thank you for asking
thank you very much
you